dites moi quelque chose que je ne sais
pas alors lancement de jingle on s'en
fout vous allez tous me dire si vous
avez quelque chose à apprendre à
quelqu'un ici autour de ça tape ça peut
être moi ça peut être n'importe qui
d'accord et moi aussi j'aurai quelque
chose à dire à quelqu'un ici ah oui on
ne le sait pas voilà et bien
figurez-vous que monsieur jean michel
maire prépare en secret une pièce de
théâtre pour septembre
ça s'appelait quoi kim à l'oignon et
dans mon pied ça s'appelle
l'anniversaire mardi aux abords des
locaux partenaires
tonya kinzinger n'ont appris le soleil
j'adore tonia ne sais pas comment il
cessa et baboo ça va mais c'est un truc
qui ne savaient pas les trucs alors mais
j'en ai rien à [ __ ] de l'émission
benoît savard vote poussant tabac et six
en colère qu'est ce qui nous revient
avec l'humanisme attendu le pouce et
donc il est foulée aux maîtres comme
s'appuyer comme ça et puis comme ça ici
j'ai eu mal papilles et il sourit je
peux pas appeler appuyé à bas puis à les
appuyer
mais c'est fait c'est fait un effort
mais ça va il a mal non parce que c'est
peut-être votre tronc qui vous feront
[Rires]
pas mal je n'ai rien fait je suis
maintenant il est où ce 12e et un ace
qui n'est pas bleu mon pouce mais par
rapport à l'instar du salat merci les
tordus et bleu mais voilà il a dit la
vérité lors qu'en voulu me frapper dans
les loges voilà voilà
et je les aime beaucoup la haie
mais aussi toi je le frappe à illies
attaque moi c'est vrai et nightfall
matraque
bédard benjamin non sa voix et sa femme
quoi laquelle benjamin castaldi peut
faire ajoute cette femme y est c'est
fait y a pas de grand père de père s'est
alors battu l'as fan numéro six semaines
mais non whissell l'unique et son jeu
j'adore aussi haut
ils sont sur les tous les deux en train
de préparer un pilote pour une émission
de radio pour une matinale ouais je sais
pour chinon non non non vous savez donc
chez moi elle va vous le savez mais
c'est super idée mais tu vas être super
ça va être super à laisser du temps
est-ce que tout à mes cyril que bientôt
vous aurez un corps de rêve
[Rires]
excuse moi tu es d'engagement potable
mais qu'est ce que ton travail
non mais c'était non mais c'est
d'inviter gentiment par donc je dois
t'arrêter
tu vois pas tu te rates et ouais c'est
vrai mais on va pas non mais je suis
voilà ce que je viens on vient de le
mettre en contact avec un coach de sport
qui est incroyable de toute mon équipe
et franchement il a dit qu'il va te
faire un truc de dingue juridique
puisque je travaille en particulier
oui le haut le bas berry 2003 on a donné
les trois mois qu'est ce que vous voulez
développer parisot bien heureusement
haut niveau je vous ai déjà qu'il est
très bien j'ai des très belles jambes
oui c'est vrai les molaires son frère
vous êtes étoffé vrai nom je vais
travailler
les abonnés un haka la sangle abdominale
parce que je dois près je prépare l'été
et cet été je serai sur toute la côte
est de la cordillère des andes à voilà
pour ceux qui chercheraient les cherry
qui a quelque chose à dire sur quelqu'un
vous ok les relations seraient m'ont
jamais rêvé assurément c'est grave je
passais des gens s'en foutent
sinon les gens s'en foutent pas tant que
raymond ne se contente pas de livrer des
colis pendant la journée la nuit ou s'il
s'imagine livrer des orgasmes à
certaines chroniqueuse non mais valéry
mézague valérie bénaïm exactement alors
vous êtes sûr que c'est des organes on
est heureux c'est quoi cette équipe on
sait qu'il a fait un rêve est chiche un
rêve et roadster érotique ya quelques
jours il a vu belle et l'e mailing
toquer à sa porte
non il a ouvert la porte valérie bénaïm
tonné une marmite valérie benaïm lui dis
tout de suite à raymond elle est chaude
raimondi killam arbitres et belles rimes
et linkedin aux oies et c'est vraiment
sourd elles sont vraiment ses frères tu
étais malade qui a balancé ça bah ça tu
es ici pour rien dire il ya même un
deuxième rêve où on est parti dans un
pack dare-dare d'attraction
l'attraction osiris osiris nu tous les
deux et leur enceinte 9,2 dans assez fou
merci en fait ils soient touchés attend
dé voir là à dire qu'il m'apprécie leur
mission est de poursuivre à l'ériger
vous dire d'avoir du succès à n'importe
quel âge c'est important mais sur une
civière et non pas du tout je vais parce
que vous êtes mac et tout ça aille c'est
toujours bien d'avoir du succès non
content moi c'était un rêve érotique je
vous jure que c'est vrai arrête sur
isabelle c'est pas du tout un cauchemar
vous n'êtes pas nier si ça se trouve
vous seriez pas déçu mais écoutez ça se
trouvera peut-être un jour ça reste
cachée non mais mika ben moi je suis
juste et comment est ce qu'il sait le
nouvel ace et où il connaît tous les
numéros thing restauration d'un numéro
vert dès qu'un mec c'est un numéro
érotique il a pas une numéro est ce que
quelqu'un quelque chose d'intéressant à
dire sur quelqu'un vous je le sens pas
ah ah ah 6i secure qui sait si un jour
vous voulez virer gilet beige vous jure
que je viens de découvrir un truc à voir
si l'ordre est incroyable que je ne
savais pas que m'a raconté un
restaurateur jeu de zombies
non ceux réservés et un le truc qui le
rend malade mais qui le rend malade
il a fait ça dans un restaurant le
restaurateur la porte et intrus il est
parti en renversant une table tellement
il était fou de rage et vous savez ce
que c'était c'est quoi je vous jure que
c'est vrai c'était des endives braisées
des choux de bruxelles
non non tu vois quoi c'était les on dit
quand vous avez la phobie des zones
boisées
vous at on dit vaut fob je vous ai je
vous ai déjà parlé des clowns blancs
mais ça je peux pas en parler et un
clash a envie de vomir vos mii c'est par
là
fait des rouges mendier en dix reprises
et ont brisé savait comment elles sont
maison dit elle sont brésil va me faire
vomir c'est raide il y avait encore des
parts et elles sont bien des tarés dans
cette émission c'est quoi mais on tire à
balle réelle puisque on dit au fait on
fait revenir maxime gagné in humans
émaillé parti doit maintenant qu'il est
parti pour un grand voyage vous
connaissez ou pas les feuilletons
j'aurais petite maison dans la prairie
quand il ya quelqu'un qui est mort il
est où papa non papa est en voyage
oui alors puisqu'il assure le moins
c'est une info ce sont maxime a déjà on
à l'info bah déjà l'un à l'intérieur
ouais les fringues mais c'est surtout
une info je sais qu'il va revoir des
gens de chez m6 quoi il va revoir s'il a
déjà vu des gens de 5,6 et là il va
revoir encore des gens de cm siffler les
tours et par un truc mais m6 je vous
veux mais il faut lui donner du toit
parce que si je lance à la paix même si
elle aime beaucoup mais n'hésitez pas
[Applaudissements]
on l'a d'or mais je le dis aux
dirigeants m6 ne fait pas sens catimini
prenez le 3 août et doit bordel bouffer
la côte jakub smrz aérien avec m6
c'est dommage et avec alex goude
n'existe pas non plus oui ça arrive
parce qu'il va faire un spectacle de
magie et même si ça va être peut-être
partenaires ou non d'accord est proposé
chez m6 c'est lui qui sont une intox en
corse et dans un collège privé assez
régulièrement et je crois que moi tout a
joué les trois que vichy il arrive à
sauver un orangina stopper ma succès là
bas
oui tu fais là bas ayé une conférence de
l'île de la tentation quoi vous allez
voilà comment ça mais on a la tentation
est vite ça le connaît ouais je vais te
dire je suis soulagé non
c'est comme quand on lui demande oui
s'il était chez pizza pino avec une meuf
ou et kelly ou si l'info je ne sens pas
le sens pas maxime attention tu sais je
t'aime beaucoup ne me fais pas de mal'
va en faire la guerre moi je suis en
camion tu fais pas gaffe à wade avait
nourri m6 en camion le livreur avec le
masque ya vraiment une heure trop sympa
sinon à vous merde excusez moi c'est le
soja ses factures ici c'est super l'a
tuée mais qu'il fut l'ex garde non la
chemise de temps dans l'émission qui
sera fait c'est quoi ton scoop en
ukraine figure toi qui est un animateur
t écoute confondez pas la même séquence
de relève de merde
sk marque elle a dit moi quelque chose
que je n'ai pas fait un chroniqueur
serein prenez que ah ouais il existe la
séquence sur l'ukraine
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
c'est trop pour moi
la dame est arrivée en ukraine au froid
de canard qui se dit qu'on va avoir
l'info jeu en ukraine ce qui s'est passé
oui vous l'aura pour le moment est-ce
que tard d'eau sur un coup de coeur
personne ne s'est en fait kelly plus
jeunes ouais était la jolie fille qui
accompagnait gims c'est pas vrai
et les mecs tout les russes étaient
décapités
on descend là dessus bravo tu vois tu as
fait une très belle et bien vous allez
vite amena derniers 12 mois
oui moi oui vous préférez celui de kelly
deux minutes oui moi j'ai quelque chose
sur valérie oui oui moyennement oui bah
oui qu'est-ce qui se cache derrière son
sourire une marmite
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
elle est que tous les éditeurs de paris
non des marchés n'ont essayé de
comprendre qui était valérie benaïm je
te lance aux fidji non si oui oui et
elle écrit un livre à lire ml absolument
absolument vous saviez pas vraiment
comprendre beaucoup d'argent ils en ont
rigolé le boss el bassel bas sur ton
blog alors et c'est tout un des rares
fournisseurs avec madame oui j'ai appris
que doc quand il était petit se faisait
appeler cap aussi non non c'est moi
pourquoi
et parce que j'avais inventé de machines
ce qu'ils étaient courts et de sucré qui
pouvait extraire le lait du café ah
ouais non ça va tu est un inventeur toi
ça fait dock 30 appelés doc d'ailleurs
il ya eu une époque où tout le monde
était branché c'est ap cuisine we can i
cours et oui mais moi j'ai jamais
accepter ce genre de cursus fouet aux
pieds j'ai je me suis orientée sur sur
ce que j'ai trouvé le plus intéressant
il est 2 heures 45 heure j'étais pencher
sur le mystère de la naissance et de la
procréation
merci on n'aura jamais la réponse
[Applaudissements]